any moment now texas governor greg
abbott will deliver remarks at a border
security briefing with at least a dozen
attorneys general from across the
country that's as we obtained that
dramatic new video of a federal
contractor discussing undocumented
migrants being transported on secret
charter flights into suburban
communities joining us now is former
acting ice director and fox news
contributor tom homan tom let me get
your immediate reaction to what we saw
in that video with a contractor saying
essentially that that is video of the
government betraying the american people
his shame phone's disgusting and that
video proves like i've been saying all
year that the secretary of homeland
security is lying to the american people
when he says he's using title 42 to
return uh people to mexico he's lying
all these adult males you see on this
video every one of them qualified for
the return of mexico he's not doing it
but he tells members of congress during
testimony he's doing it he tells the
media is doing it every one of those
males
are also eligible for detention they can
be detained ice is at like 50 detention
right now he's lying to american people
and this film pulls a curtain back on
him this secretary needs to be removed
our homeland is less secure under his
leadership
tom remember back to the campaign trail
two years ago you had so many of the
abolish ice chance going on and we heard
from then canada joe biden wasn't going
to abolish ice but has is effectively
the equivalent happened
he abolished their mission
i says
ice cannot enforce the law anymore he
has come out within the last two weeks
and said you can't arrest somebody from
just being here legally he's telling an
immigration officer who's sworn to
enforce the immigration law that you
can't arrest someone for being an
illegal alien what kind of message does
that send to the rest of the world when
we're dealing with the border crisis
like we are they haven't released the
ice report yet because there's going to
be an embarrassment and i've been told
to go and turn that rights report all
around so we can't understand it the men
and women of ice are devastated the
morale is non-existent same with the
border patrol that's why they jumped
over the secretary yesterday in the town
hall meeting right let me address that
so i spoke with the border patrol
president brandon judd who you know well
a couple hours ago he said griff border
patrol is broken and specifically when
you saw that exchange in yuma yesterday
but before i play that
there was a moment last week i happened
to watch it it got zero coverage it was
dhs secretary alejandro mayorkas
speaking to the conference of mayors
about the border here is what he said
listen
unlawful presence in the united states
will alone
not be a basis for an immigration
enforcement action but rather
we will allocate
our efforts we will allocate our
resources on those individuals who
present
a current public safety threat
a threat to national security
or a threat to our border security and
that is a very important principle
so last week he tells the entire world
it's okay to come then yesterday in um
arizona this happens in exchange with
agents
it may appear that everyday in turkey
story we know better i know better the
commitment remains and we'll keep
fighting
and let me let me just say you can turn
your back on me but i'll never turn your
back and my back on you you did the day
you were appointed
tom your thoughts
amen he turned her back on then the same
with the president they both abandoned
the men and women in the board patrol it
tells you something grip that border
patrol was broken when he got a uniform
officer taking on a cabinet member the
secretary and the secretary should be
ashamed of himself and what did he offer
them well we're going to ask mexico to
do more we're going to ask mexico to do
our job for us well president trump told
mexico they're going to do more on the
border but at the same time he built a
border wall he ended catch and release
he detained people
he actually enforced the law he had
title 42 he had to remain in mexico
president trump did what this country
needed he let the men and women wearing
that green uniform do their job this
secretary says well we're going to ask
mexico to do more he needs to be removed
and this comes on the heels of the cbp
commission whose cbp commissioner chris
magnus went down had the same town hall
a couple weeks ago and tells him if you
don't like to policy this administration
then you can quit he says this crisis
isn't due to our policies it's due to a
lack of manpower that guy is it has no
clue because a lack of manpower is
directly related to the crisis which is
caused by the policies if he don't get
that then he's way over his head well it
sure seems like there is a problem that
the administration needs to address we
would like to invite secretary marquez
or anyone else in border patrol
leadership to come on this show tom
homan thank you for taking time and for
giving us your insight hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now